kein krieg rufen die demonstranten in
moskau eigentlich wollen sie an diesem
abend zum aussenministerium um gegen die
teil mobilisierung zu protestieren aber
die staatsmacht greift durch
unsere leute dürfen nicht sterben unsere
mütter haben schon
sagt dieser mann noch dem zdf-team dann
wird er abgeführt hunderte menschen vor
allem in größeren städten des landes
werden an diesem tag festgenommen
ich habe söhne wir wollen mit niemandem
kämpfen niemanden töten ich möchte sie
nicht als leichen zurückbekommen und in
der ukraine
das sind auch die kinder von jemandem
wir wollen diesen krieg nicht
es gibt berichte wonach viele russen
versuchen das land noch zu verlassen
rund 300.000 reservisten könnten nun zum
kampf in der ukraine eingezogen werden
gestern früh hatte präsident putin in
einer fernsehansprache die teil
mobilisierung bekannt gegeben außerdem
sollen schon ab freitag in den besetzten
gebieten so genannte volksabstimmungen
über den anschluss an russland
abgehalten werden so wie bei der
annexion der krim auch diese gebiete
wären dann teil des russischen
territoriums
bei einer gefährdung der territorialen
integrität russland werden wir unbedingt
alle mittel einsetzen die uns zur
verfügung stehen dies ist kein bluff
es ist eine nukleare drohung damit hat
putin der weltgemeinschaft die sich an
diesem tag in new york bei den vereinten
nationen zur vollversammlung trifft das
thema diktiert
diese jahre rede und rhetorik von
präsident putin ist gefährlich und
rücksichtslos
das zeigt wie verzweifelt der russische
präsident ist weil es militärisch nicht
so vorangeht wie er sich das vorgestellt
hat eigentlich war ja sein plan das muss
man sich nochmal glaube ich in
erinnerung rufen dass er nach dem 24
februar innerhalb von ein paar tagen
kiew einnimmt
ausnahmegenehmigung dann für den
ukrainischen präsidenten der sich wegen
des krieges per videobotschaft meldet
russland redet über verhandlungen aber
verkündet die militärische mobilmachung
sie reden über verhandlungen aber können
die gebäude referenten in dem besetzten
gebiet in der ukraine an
große bühne für sie lenski in new york
proteste und festnahmen in russland der
krieg ist der russischen gesellschaft
seit gestern näher gekommen
für uns in moskaus christian selben
guten morgen christian gestern also die
ankündigung der teilmobilmachung das hat
für vereinzelte demonstrationen gesorgt
im gesamten land wie ordnet zu dieser
ersten reaktion ein
ja schon guten morgen also diese
nachricht hat auch viele russen gestern
kalt erwischt obwohl es ja schon länger
gerüchte gab dass das passieren kann wir
haben dann gestern erlebt das dann doch
viele noch versucht haben fluchtartig
das land zu verlassen es gab 30
kilometer lange staus an der grenze von
russland nach finnland dort haben einige
versucht das land zu verlassen flug
buchen sind in die höhe geschossen die
ländern die russen noch visafrei reisen
können also zb nach armenien oder in die
türkei oder ein flug nach dubai kostete
auf einmal 5000 euro also das im
wahrsten sinne des wortes panik bei
vielen ausgebrochen es gab auch
meldungen gestern dass viele die grenze
dann auch nicht mehr passieren konnten
an den flughäfen dass männer im
wehrfähigen alter dann auch
zurückhaltend wurden und das land nicht
mehr verlassen konnten und dann wurde er
gestern auch zu demonstrationen
aufgerufen die gab es in über 40 städten
und wir waren selbst gestern abend
unterwegs und wussten auch nicht wie
viele werden diesem aufruf folgen denn
nach den repressionen der letzten wochen
und monaten war ja nicht klar ob
menschen sich das wirklich noch trauen
und einige trauten sich das gestern in
moskau gestern abend auch einige hundert
waren das und die polizei ist massiv
dazwischen gegangen die bilder haben wir
auch im beitrag gesehen mit einer
enormen brutalität wie wir sie hier
lange nicht erlebt haben
teilmobilmachung christian heißt ja
jetzt wohl mehrere 100.000 soldaten zu
mobilisieren und alle fragen sich wie
schnell kann das jetzt gehen
es gibt immer noch verwirrung bei vielen
russen die sich fragen betrifft mich das
jetzt oder nicht also dass die
unklarheit noch bei vielen groß schnell
wird das aber nicht gehen also die dies
betrifft die werden dann ihren
einberufungsbescheid auf dem ein oder
anderen weg erhalten und dann hat
verteidigungsminister shaul gestern ja
auch angekündigt dass die das betrifft
dann erst noch mal eine ausbildung
kriegen also auf den einsatz vorbereitet
werden und ich denke nicht dass das
jetzt eine sache von tagen ist sondern
das wird dann wenn das dann so kommen
sollte er mehrere wochen dauern über die
teilmobilmachung die angekündigte in
russland und die reaktion haben wir mit
christian slam in moskau gesprochen
vielen dank